alors avant d'interroger nos invités
tout de suite à un coup de projecteur
sur un autre nouvel arrivant
robert badinter ministre de la justice
paul le faire vous allez être un garde
des sceaux dont les convictions les
déclarations seront parfois à
contre-courant de l'opinion de la
majorité des français je parle au niveau
de la ces qui la notion de sécurité
aussi ou sur le plan d'athènes de mort
ça doit pas être facile d'être le
représentant de la justice dans ce cas
là non ce qui concerne le problème de la
sécurité est cet égard
j'aurai l'occasion de l'expliquer les
voies de la sécurité ne passe pas
nécessairement par ce qu'on a appelé en
son temps un voie dite de sécurité
en ce qui concerne pleinement que vous
évoquez je n'ai pas besoin de rappeler
que le président de la république dans
le cours de la campagne a fait
publiquement connaître son opinion il a
été élu moi je pense que cet égard il
leur suffit d'éclairer et de combattre